foreign
today we will take you through a hands
of lab demo of how we can use deep
learning models for image classification
using CNN for amazing video like this
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
press the Bell icon to stay updated in
today's session we will discuss what
deep learning is and moving ahead we
will cover what is neural network and in
the end we will do a hands of lab demo
of flower image classification using CNN
so what is deep learning deep learning
is a subset of machine learning that
deals with algorithm inspired by the
structure and function of the brain and
which is a part of artificial
intelligence AI deep learning is widely
used to make weather predictions about
rain earthquakes and tsunamis it helps
in taking the necessary precautions with
deep learning machine can comprehend the
speech and provide the required output
it enables the machines to recognize
people and object in the images fed to
it
deep learning models also help
Advertiser leverage data to perform
real-time bidding and Target display
advertising so what is neural network to
understand how an artificial neuron
works we should first understand how a
biological neuron works
so this is one of a biological neuron
so dendrites these receive information
or signals from other neurons that get
connected to it
the second one is cell body information
processing happens in a cell body these
take and all the information coming from
the different dendrites and process that
information
the last one is X1
it sends the output signals to other
neuron for the flow of information here
each of the flank is connected to the
dendrite or the hairs on the next one
now let's see a neural network to
so this image show an a n
okay
so the network start with an input layer
that receives input in data form the
lines connected to the hidden layers are
called weights and they add upon the
hidden layers each dot in the hidden
layer processes the inputs and it puts
one output into the next hidden layer
and lastly into the output layer
so here input to a neuron is known as
input layer and the actual neuron is
called hidden layer and the output of
the next neuron is called output layer a
neural network is a system of Hardware
or software patterned after the
operation of neurons in the human brain
neural network also called artificial
neural network are a means of achieving
deep learning and the demand for machine
learning and AI is growing faster than
that of other profession in fact
according to statistic there will be
more than 2.3 million job opening in the
field of artificial intelligence and
machine learning by 2023 so
repeat but you can beat the curve with
our professional certificate program in
Ai and ml Co is sponsored by Purdue
University and IBM this course covers
tools and techniques like numpy pandas
Python and sci-fi along with industry
project like social media by Twitter
delivery service provider by zomato and
transportation service provider by Uber
choosing this course can get you hired
in renowned companies like Netflix
Amazon Facebook and Adobe with an
average salary hike of 70 so what are
you waiting for join the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning and Excel your career into
machine learning the link is in
description box below now let's move to
the programming part so this is a python
kernel file
okay
so here I will change the name deep
red
python
and we will do flower recognition using
CNN okay
so
first what I will do I will import
OS
and here I will write print
OS dot list directory
then
see
slash users
slash
zero nine three seven five
plus desktop this is the path of that
folder where I have put the images
class
okay
so let's run it yeah so we have five
categories in flowers like Desi 10
Julian Rose sunflower and tulip okay I
will provide you the zip file or these
data set
so now import some major libraries
so here I will write import
warnings
then burning
dot filter warnings
[Music]
always
okay these are just the warnings
when warnings come it will ignore or it
will always
warnings
then here I will write ignore
okay then let's import some libraries
for data visualization and manipulation
so here I will write import
numpy
numpy as NP
then import
pandas as
PD
to my bed
import Point as SPD
then
import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
then from matplotlib
import
Style
don't worry we will discuss
each of the library
then import
c bond
as SNS
so what is numpy
this one numpy
so numpa is a python Library used for
working with that is it also has a
function for working in the domain of
lineal algebra and matrices it is an
open source means free project and you
can use it freely numpy stand for
numerical Python and the second one is
pandas panda is a software Larry written
for the Python programming language for
data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structure and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
then the third one is matplotlib
so for Python and its numerical
extension numpy matte broadleaf is a
cross-platform data visualization and
graphical charting package as a result
it represents a strong open source
substitute for Matlab the api's
application programming interfaces for
Matlock allows programmers to
incorporate graphs to GUI applications
okay
so mad plotlet import style or splt why
we are writing splt as PDS NP because we
don't have to write again and again this
the long sentence in my plotlip.lot okay
we can import using short name PLT
then fourth one is import c bond
so C bone is a python data visualization
Library based on matrotip it provides a
high level interface for drawing
attractive and informative statical
graph for a brief introduction to the
ideas behind the library you can read
the introductory notes or the papers
from the website
okay
so now let's configure let's set smart
broadly to inline and display graph
below the corresponding cell vertical
responding cells so for that I will
write here person
matplotlib
inline
okay
then here I will write the style
dot use
this is one of the style so here I will
add 5 38.
okay then SNS dot set
equals to White grid
comma color
codes
Picasso
approach
okay let's import some major libraries
for model selection so for that I will
write here from sqlarn
dot model
selection
code
train
test
split
okay
then I will add from
sklearn Dot model
selection
import
then here from
sqln
Dot
model
sorry here let matrices
Matrix
then import
crazy
code
comma Precision score
comma recall score
comma confusion Matrix
comma
Roc curve
Roc
okay
then here I can import Roc
AUC
score
so now we will import
some
more like from
skeleton dot model
selection
import
grid
Siri
then from SQL line
Dot pre-processing
code
label encoder
so what is strain test split
okay this sqln model selection 10 test
split
so trend has split to getting training
and test sets
this control the size of subset with the
parameter train size and test size
so determine the randomness of your
splits with the random State parameter
obtained specified splits with the
stratified matter
okay then k fold
k-fold is again a validation technique
in which we split the data into K
subsets and the holdout method is
repeated K times
where each of the K subsets are used as
a test and other K1 subset are used for
the training purpose
this accuracy scope decision score
recall score confusion Matrix Roc curve
and Roc accuracy curve so these all are
for the the accuracy to check the
accuracy what will the Precision score
and the ROC curve graph for making
graphs and all
okay these are for metrics
then grid search CV
so gritsar CV is a technique for finding
the optimal parameter values from a
given set of parameters in a grid
it essentially a cross validation
technique so the model as well as the
parameter must be entered
so this is after extracting the best
parameter values the prediction are made
okay
so this label encoder so label encoding
is a popular encoding technique for like
handling categorical values
okay or variables you can say so in this
technique or method you can say each
label is assigned a unique integer based
on alphabetical order
okay
so
now for pre-processing I will import
something
so here I will add from
KS Dot
utils
not pre-processing
dot image
image
data
generator
okay yeah
so this is for the pre-processing of the
image so image data generator what does
it allows your model to receive new
variation of the images at each epoch
Okay so
but do you remember that it only returns
a transform images and does not add it
to the set of images that you have like
for in our data set
okay
just it is used for the transform in
image
now let's import some deep learning
libraries so here I've learned from
Keras
Keras import
backend
as k
okay then another one is strong okay
this dot model
s
Port sequential
then from
applicators
dot layers
okay from
Keras Dot
optimizers
important
Adam
SGD
these are all are the optimizers
Ada grad
comma 88
e
Ada
okay then last one is RMS from
then from
Keras
Dot
utilize
both
to categorical
okay
so cares
Keras is a model level liability
providing high level building blocks for
developing deep learning models it does
not handle itself
low level operations such as like tensor
products or convolutions and so on
and this sequential
okay
to sequential the core idea of
sequential API is simply arranging the
chaos layers in a sequential order and
so
it is also called sequential API like
most of the a n also has layers in
sequential order and the data flows from
one layer to another layer in the given
order until the data finally reaches the
output layer
and this dense
so Kira's dance layer is a layer that
contains all the neurons that are deeply
connected within in themselves
this means that every neuron in the
dense layer takes the input from all the
other neurons of the previous layer so
we can add as many as dense layer as
required
so dance is the one of the most commonly
used layers in deep learning
and these optimizers Adam SGD Ada grad
Ada Delta
so optimizers are classes or methods
used to change the attributes of your
machine or deep learning model such as
weight and learning rate in order to
reduce the losses
so Optimizer helps to get result faster
then this K result
will return the binary value Matrix
which contains the values either 0 or 1.
it contains an equal number of rows from
the length of the input vector and
column number which was equal to the
class number which we defined in our
code
okay
so
now let's import for CNN
so here I will write from Keras
Dot
okay this dot layers
import
drop out
flatten
and then from
Keras
dot layers
board
2D
than Max pooling
next pulling 2D
batch normalization
okay
so these are some more layers for the
CNN for particular CNN
then import
tensorflow
as TF
then import
random as
r
then random is used for finding the
random value
then let's specifically for manipulating
zipped images and getting numpy arrays
of pixel value of images let's import
that
so here I will write import CV2
then from
tqdm
port
ticket
okay
then I will write import
OS
look at the spaces
then from
random
import
Shuffle
then from
zip file
okay import
ant zip file
then from
pil
OT board
image
so tensorflow is an end-to-end open
source platform for machine learning and
deep learning tensorflow is a race
system for managing all aspect of
machine learning system however this
class focus on using a particular
tensorflow API to develop and train
machine learning models okay try notice
so tqdm means like progress and it is
used to create a smart progress bar for
the loops
okay now let's run this
and see any error
okay there is one error
great search CV
where is that grid searching
okay as you'll be Capital here
okay a processing maybe processing
spelling is wrong I guess
pre-processing
see
okay this is the spelling mistake
the minor spelling mistakes
okay here here is dot optimizers import
Adam so what can help import name Ada
Delta why because a should be Capital
here
a will be Capital here
okay
now module name KS Dot
utils
okay
one more
the last one I guess so
cannot import names zip file
zip file import
zip file
okay
these are some
any mistakes you can say
while importing
so now what we will do next we will
prepare the data and make the functions
to get the training and modulation set
from the images okay
so here I will write x equals to
blank array
is that
okay
then
image
size equals to 32.
then we will import all the because we
have one particular folder named flowers
and on that we have four folder or five
folder like with one Daisy one once
learn sunflower one two lip one
dandelion one rows okay so we have to
you know import each of folder one by
one so here I've let fly
Daisy
from directory
okay
and the directory is
I can copy from here
okay
and paste it here
then
everyday
okay so don't worry I will provide you
the zip file
Drive Link
okay you can check from the description
box below
and here I will fly
simpler
directory equals to
then here
okay and here I will add flat
tulip
directory
question
my folder names
so
yeah
then the directory
equals to
arrival at 10 billion
floor
rows
directory
okay
then close
so now let's open create function
label
to image
plotted
okay
then I will write here return
then
what I will do here
I will import some OAS FN match and make
train data
okay so I will add here import
ant match
then I will write import OS
then death making function
make
chain
data
then plot
time comma
directory
foreign
for the loop I said
OS dot list directly
please directly from Dio
okay
then here I will write if and match
dot fm match
image
star dot jpg click anything.jpg
then label
equals to sine
level two
image of flower type
okay
then path
question OS dot path
dot join
directory
images
that image equals to CV2
down I am read
the path
comma CV2
I am read
color
okay
then I will write an image equals to CV2
dot resize
CB2 is opencb file
liability image comma
I am this size
comma I am precise
okay
then here I will write x dot app and
these x and z
x dot app and
MP dot array
image
then
okay X is capital there
Z dot append
Str label
string level
okay so now let's run it yeah it's cool
so here we will check the all the you
know length
of the training data set for particular
Day Z that sunflower Road
so here let's make
train
data
Daisy
comma
flaw
Daisy
okay
then I will print the length of like how
many photos are there
so as you can see
there are total 764
so now like this we'll check for all
so here let me copy this and paste this
here
I will write
those
rows then join it
so Rose has one five eight four
so it's flower rose
so now we'll check
for sunflower
like this one here
sunflower
yeah I will write
okay three zero six five
then here I will write for
to live
tulip
so there are four four zero four nine
last one
10 trillion
10 billion and here I have to write
okay
so first let me tell you about the data
set
so this data set contains like four to
four two images of flowers
okay 4242. so that data collection is
based on the data flicker or Google
Images we took or why index images
and you can you can use this data set to
recognize plants from the photo
and the picture divided into five five
classes like chameleon tulips row Supply
and dead alien and for each class there
are about 800 photos
okay not like all 800 but 800 photos
like photos are not that much high
resolution about 320 into 4 to 40 pixels
are there so photos are not reduced to a
single size they have different
different proportion
okay
so what I will do that I will give
space
now let's visualize some random images
okay
so here I will write figure comma 3x
equals to PLT Dot
subplots
then 5 comma two
then figure dot set
size
inches
15 comma 15.
Then Fall
I
range
five
then
four
J and
range
to like five or two
okay 10 images will come
then what I will write
then L equals to RN Dot
random input
comma lens set
okay then ax
I comma J
dot I am sure
x l
a x
I comma 2
dot set
of Titan
Plus
plus Z
okay
then PLT
Dot
type layout this is one of the layout
of showing photos
okay let's do it
so these are some random image of
sunflower that rows
so I already said you these pictures are
not that high quality okay
that flower rose is there than to live
so moving forward let's label encoding
with that y arrays like Daisy rows let
days equals zero rho is equal to one
then one Auto encoding
so for that we'll write here
l equals to
label
encoder
and then
y equals to
Ali
Dot fit transform
Z
okay
then y equals to
categorical
y comma five
equals to NP Dot
array
X
then X equals to
X by 255
okay
okay there is no car by comma five
extra
yeah so now what we will do we will
split into training and testing
validation sets okay for that I will
attack strain
comma
X test
y train
a while test
equals to train
test
plate we already described what is 10
test plate let's go to y
comma test
size
equals to 0.25
comma
random
date
equals to 42
okay
so now let's set the random seeds so for
that I will write NP dot random
Dot
seat
then RN
dot C
is again 42
TF
Dot
random dot set
42.
okay what we will do now we will do
modeling we will build a convet net
model convert net means CNN model
so for that I will write here
like model equals to
sequential
okay
then model dot at
2D
then
filters
equals to 128.
then kernel size
the question
2 comma 2
trading will be
same
[Music]
comma activation
layer
then input
shape
question
input shape equals to
32 comma 32 comma three
then here I will write model dot add
Max
pooling
2D then
the whole size
because so 2 comma 2
then I will write model dot at
flatten
then model dot add
tense
okay T will be Capital here
then 512 these all are for the layers
the model dot add
activation
that reload
then model dot at
dance
five
comma
activation
equals to
softmax
okay then let me run it
go into 2D D will be capital
okay
it is
kernel size
yeah it's running
so now what I will do
I will do using a Allen and a layer we
will set the best side we will set the
box and we will do the callbacks or not
okay so for that I will write
badge
batch size
equals to 45
then a box
will be 10
then from Keras
dot callbacks
four
reduce
LR
on RedTube
Eau
okay
then I will add
a lot equals to
videos
alaron
plateau
then we'll monitor
close to validation score
patience
equals to three
comma bubbles
Factor
equals zero point
okay
so moving forward what we will do we
will do the data documentation to
prevent overfitting so now let's do the
data augmentation for that I will not
here Theta
it's in close to
image
generator
then here I will write feature
feature wise
future wise
Center
equals to
false
so what this line will do this line will
do like set input mean to 0 over the
data set
okay
then I will write sample wise
Center
equals to
false
now this set e sample mean to zero
right here
Center
equals to false
so what it will do
no no it's the feature wise I will write
standard normalization
standard normalization because so
false
so it divides input by standardization
of the data set
okay
then
sample wise
standard
normalization
question
false
then it divide each input by its
standardization
this time
then
I will write here let's see a white me
because you false
applies that sea whitening
then
rotation
range
and rotation range equals to 10.
it will what it will do it will randomly
rotate image in the range like degree 0
to 180.
okay
then
Zoom
range
equals to 0.1
this is for randomly zooming image
then
shift
range equals to 0 0.2
then but it will do it will randomly
shift images horizontally like fraction
of total width
[Music]
range question
0.2
it is for randomly shift image
vertically like fraction of total height
and this horizontal
flip equals
true
for randomly
flipping images this is for vertical
voice
okay
then data chain dot fit
next train
summer is there
it is like width shift range
0.2
okay
so let's debug this error
so let's run this again
yeah it's gone
so now what we will do we will compile
the Keras model and see the summary
for that I will write here model Dot
compile
compile at this Optimizer we already
know what are the optimizer because to
add them
R equals to
0.001
okay then
last question
categorical
cross
B
comma
Matrix
because of
curacy
okay let's run this
first let me give some spaces
yeah
so here
let's see the model summary
so as you can see here the layer types
like con 2D or Max pooling 2D
so output shape is 30 to 30 to 128 and
the parameters are given is 164. flatten
is again the layer dances again the
layer
okay so total parameter use 16
this much and the trainable parameters
are this
okay
so moving forward let's
fit
let's do the fitting on the training set
and making prediction on the very
validation set
okay
so let's write history
[Music]
generator
dot flow
extreme
comma or a train
comma
batch size
equals to
badge size
okay
comma
a box
request to box
validation
data equals to
X test comma y test
equals to one
commas steps
well
bulk
equals to X
train dot shape
zero
Edge size
okay so let's run this so it will take
time like it will run till
10 approx of 85
okay from this we can get the accuracy
for the validation
so I hope you understand till here if
you have any question regarding machine
learning deep learning python you can
comment or you can check our course from
the description box below
it will take a little bit of time
so after this we will save this model
and
from
then from tensorflow will import
then we will do some model performance
evaluative model performance
after that we will recreate the exact
same model like including its weight and
optimizer
then at the last we will visualize
our correctly classified cloud images
predicted one
okay
so five are done five more money
okay like three more
if you have any problem and like go in
understanding the code you can comment
down below
or don't forget to check the course from
the description box below
okay
AIML courses
last one is remaining
what we will do we will save this model
into kaggle only
okay
so here I will write model dot C
again
[Music]
Model 12 point
H5
okay this time accuracies came
validation accuracy six four four two
zero point six four four two accuracy
is six six okay
so now from
tensorflow
support
Gators
then model
the models
let's dot load
[Applause]
model
okay then
12.5
here
I will do the save I will save the model
to the disk and load model from the disk
so let me write the code for that and
get back to you
so saved model to disk and loaded model
from disk
so now let's evaluate the model
performance okay for that I will use
this
better visual so here we'll plot
plt.plot
tree Dot
stray
loss
okay then PLT Dot Plot
history
dot history
validation loss
then PL guitar
you can say model loss
and PLT Dot y level
the loss
mpnt dot X label
box
imagine
train
come on
death
yeah they don't show
so as you can see the graph
of that this is a training and this is
testing loss
how much we lost
okay
so now let's see for the accuracy one
the LT Dot
Dot
history
thought
three
accuracy
okay
then PLT Dot Plot
history
Dot
three
validation accuracy
done
right done
model accuracy
MP at the DOT
why level
high level should be like accuracy
PLT dot X label
will be box
then PLT dot Legend
training
from test
the PLT
Dot
sure
so
you can see the accuracy
this is the accuracy of the training
and this is for the testing
quite okay okay
so now let's recreate the exact same
model including its weights and
optimizers like then we will see the
summary then again we will do the epox
OKAY model fitting
for the better accuracy
okay
so for recreating the model I will write
here
model
TF dot get us
models Dot
load model
dot H5
then
new
model
okay
now what I will do
I will
run a new model dot fit
train comma for a train
Oklahoma
box
size
question
bed size
validation
data
equals to
fix
test comma white test
okay
model dot with best size
new model that fifth extreme white train
box
thank you
this time I think we'll get good
accuracy
okay after that we can predict
so again this will run till 10 what does
it five six seven eight nine ten
okay
if you have any doubted here you can
please comment down below
okay if you have any queries related to
python machine learning
oh don't forget to check the course link
it will go till 10.
or if you want this full code
just comment down below for the same I
will provide you the traveling
five more left
as you can see here accuracy
is increasing
okay with the new model
okay two more left
the accuracies
copy like 99 percent
okay
after this we will save the model and
visualize the prediction of the
validation set
foreign
okay
so now let's save the model
[Applause]
okay so now we will visualize the
prediction on the validation set that I
will write the code and get back to you
okay so here now uh we have what we are
doing we are storing some properly as
well as the misclassified indexes
okay
so here it's like
proper classes this is misclatified
classes okay and here we are loading the
model predicting
so let me run it
till 40 okay
so let's see the correctly classified
flower images okay for that I will write
warnings
Dot filter on
always
then earnings
Dot filter
count equals to zero
figure comma ax
equals to PLT dots subplots
so comma two
then figure
set size
for
I
in
range
to go
for
J in
range
to
so let me write the code
okay unintendent doesn't match okay
warning spelling is strong
okay
figure
if you could Dot
okay let me debug the error and get back
to you
so as you can see it's run properly okay
see predictor flower daisy and actual
flowers is also Daisy pretty flower
sunflower
okay the photos are not you know
high quality
so that's why here you can see the rose
is seeing the rose actually
okay this Rose rows and dandelion one
then the daisy sunflower
so now what we will do we will do c like
some of the flowers are which are
misclassified okay
the same code will be there okay I will
right here
let's run this
so these are some the actual flower
tulip but with rose so these are some
misclassified images
so I hope you understand till here okay
this is the how you can do fly
recognition using deep learning with
python if you have any queries related
to python machine learning you can
comment down below
okay so thank you for watching this
video
till then stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here